สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนสู่ห้องเรียนภาษา
ไทยห้องเรียนธรรมชาติ
คนบไทยค่ะค่ะแล้วก็ในวันนี้เนาะครูกุ๊ก
กับครูชิก็มาพบกับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะในวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะครูชิวันศุกร์
วันศุกร์มีความสุขต้องยิ้มมากๆนะวันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะอุ้ยวันนี้วันที่ 1 แล้ว
เหรอคะวันที่ 1 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้
เปลี่ยนแล้วค่ะเป็นเดือนที่ 3 ชื่อ
มีนาคมค่ะปีพ.ศที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2567 ค่ะปีค.ศที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2024 ค่ะนะปีนี้เอ่อเดือนนี้เราเปลี่ยน
เดือนแล้วเนาะนะก็เป็นวันศุกร์ที่ 1
เดือนมีนาคมปีพุทธศักราช
2567 ปีคริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะนะคะแล้วก็ในวันนี้เนี่ยวันนี้
เนี่ยเรามาเจอกันเนี่ยเราก็เจอกันบ่อยๆะ
ตอนเดี๋ยวเนี้ยเราเจอกันบ่อยบๆเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราต้องคุยอะไรที่มันใหญ่ๆค่ะ
เป็นเป็นเรื่องใหญ่ๆอืเรื่องใหญ่ๆนี่
เรื่องอะไร
คะเรื่องช้างค่ะ
อ๋อเป็นสัตว์ที่ตัวใหญ่ใช่มั้ยอ้าใช่ค่ะ
เราต้องคุยเรื่องนี้เลยค่ะเรื่องของช้าง
อ่าโออนี้ใหญ่ตรงไหนคะูชิ
โอ้โหครูปุ๊กยังไม่เห็นตัวจริงนะคะครู
ปุ๊กดูสิเเนี่ยอันเนี้ย
มีงาด้วยเห็นมั้ยอ่ามีงาด้วยอันนี้ต้อง
เป็นช้างตัวผู้แน่ๆ
อือ๋อแล้วดูจากหน้าตาแล้วเนี่ยมันไม่น่า
จะเป็นช้างไทย
ค่ะนะเพราะว่าหูมันอยู่สูงน่าจะเป็นช้าง
แอฟริกา
นะแล้วก็ขาเนี่ยขายาวเนขาสูงอ่ะขายาวมาก
ใช่นะคะแต่เรามารู้จักส่วนต่างๆของช้าง
เนอะอันเนี้ย
จมูกใช่มย
อืมจมูก
ค้างครูปุ๊กนี่ครูปุ๊กงงว่าใช่จมูกหรือ
เปล่าใช่มยใช่ๆทำไมจมูกมันยาวขนาดนั้นล่ะ
คะครูชิอ้าวครูปุ๊กครูปุ๊กไม่เคยเห็น
สัตว์ที่เป็นชะมดเหรอคะก็จมูกเยวๆยาวนิด
นึงแต่จมูกช้างนี่ยาวมาก
อ๋อนะเค้าเรียกว่างวงอ้าไม่เรียกจมูกหรอ
คะเค้าเรียกว่างวงค่ะูชิเค้าไม่เรียกจมูก
แล้วจริงๆเนี่ยครูุคิดว่ามันทำหน้าที่ได้
2 อย่างเลยนะครูชิทำหน้าที่อะไรบ้าง
เอ้าก็มันน่าจะหายใจได้เนาะนะหายใจเข้า
ออกแล้วมันก็สามารถที่จะจับอะไรก็ได้โดย
ใช้งวงค่ะอ๋อเหมือนๆแบบจับมือใช่มยคือ
เหมือนใช้เออเหมือนเหมือนเหมือนเป็นแทน
มือถูกมยถูกต้องค่ะนะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยก็
เลยคิดว่านะคะมันก็เลยอไม่แน่ใจว่ามันจะ
เป็นจมูกหรือจะเป็นมือดีอ่ะค่ะูชิอ๋อแล้ว
ก็บอกว่ามันคือที่เราเรียกว่าจมูกเพราะ
ว่านอกจากมันหายใจแล้วมันสามารถ
ดมดมกลิ่นมันรู้ว่าอันเนี้ยกินได้กินไม่
มันดมค่ะมันดมกลิ่นได้ด้วย
อูนะแล้วก็ช้างเนี่ยเป็นสัตว์ประจำชาติ
ไทยเลยใช่มยูชิแต่อันเนี้ย
ช้างแอฟริกาเนี่ยมันเหมือนกับช้างเอเชีย
มยคะเหมือนช้างไทยมั้ยูชิไม่เหมือนค่ะ
เพราะว่าถ้าพูดถึงช้างไทยนะนี่ช้างไทยจะ
หูเล็กๆเห็นมั้ยคะแล้วก็มีหัว
เนี่ยนูนขึ้นมาอันนี้เป็นช้างเอเชียช้าง
อินเดียช้างไทยมีลักษณะเหมือนๆกันนะแต่
ช้างก็มีอันนี้นะอันนี้แสดงว่าอันนี้เป็น
ตัวผู้เหมือนกันมีงา
อืมงาเนี่ยจะมีในตัวผู้ใช่มั้ยคะะใช่ค่ะ
แต่เมื่อกี้เราคุยถึงงวงมันใช่มยงวงมัน
เนี่ยนอกจากดมกลิ่นเหมือนจมูกหายใจเข้า
หายใจออกแล้วเนี่ยมีหน้าที่เหมือนมือแล้ว
เนี่ยมันยังมีหน้าที่ที่สามารถเหมือนหลอด
ด้วยนะมันสามารถดูดแล้วก็พ่นน้ำได้อีก
อ้าเหมือนอะไรล่ะเหมือนปากเหรอดูดมาแล้ว
ก็เป่าออก
เหอใช่ๆๆได้เหมือนกันเนาะเพราะว่าครูก็
เห็นเหมือนกันนะเวลาช้างเนี่ยเขาจะดููด
น้ำเสร็จแล้วก็พ่นใส่่ปากตัว
เองแล้วก็พ่นใส่ปาก
อ้าเห็นมยคะครูปุ๊กว่าช้างเนี่ยเป็นสัตว์
อะไรที่พิเศษวันนี้เราเลยต้องคุยเรื่อง
ของช้างค่ะนะเห็นมั้ยล่ะแล้วก็มันเป็น
สัตว์พิเศษยังไงคะนอกจากว่าเป็นสัตว์
ประจำชาติไทยเนี่ยนะแล้วมันมีอะไรที่พิศ
เศษอีกคะูชิเอาๆเอาง่ายๆเลยนะช้างเนี่ยมี
ลักษณะนามลักษณะนามภาษาไทยต้องมีลักษณะ
นามนะอย่างเช่นคน 1 คนอืหมา 1
ตัวแมว 1 ตัวเห็นมั้ย
อ่า 1 อย่าเพิ่งนะปากกาใช่มั้ยคุอปากกา 1
ดั้มอ่าใช่มั้ยอ่ะ
ยาดม 1 อันเห็นมแว่นตา 1 อัน
โอ๊ะเห็นมั้ยต้องมีตัวที่ไปบอกลักษณะของ
สิ่งนั้นน่ะใช่มยแต่ช้างเนี่ยพิเศษค่ะ
เอ้าก็พิเศษยังไงเาก็ต้องเรียกว่าตัวสิคะ
เพราะว่าสัตว์ทุกอย่างเนี่ยเราก็เรียกว่า
แมว 1 ตัวหมา 1 ตัวนก 2 ตัวน 1 ตัว
เออแต่ช้างเพิเศษค่ะช้าง 1 ตัวเนี่ยเรา
เรียกช้างที่อยู่ในป่าแบบเนี้ยค่ะอืมเป็น
ช้างป่าใช่มั้ยอันนี้อันนี้เนี่ยน่าจะโดน
จับมาเลี้ยงแล้วค่ะครู
ชิคือช้างที่อยู่ในป่าเราเรียกว่าช้าง 1
ตัวแต่ถ้าถูกจับแล้วเอามาเลี้ยงเนี่ยเรา
เรียกว่าช้าง 1 เชือก
อืมเพราะว่าเหมือนครูบุ๊กจะเห็นว่ามันโดน
ล่ามอยู่ก็เรียกว่าช้าง 1 เชือกอ่าแต่
ช้างป่าที่อยู่ในป่าเนาะที่ประเทศไทยยัง
มีอยู่เนาะนะก็อยู่ในป่าเนี่ยก็จะเรียก
ว่าช้าง 1 ตัวช้าง 2 ตัวนะแต่ถูกจับมา
เลี้ยงแล้วเนี่ยเราจะเรียกเป็นช้าง 1
เชือกช้าง 2 เชือกอืเออแต่ที่เท่ไปกว่า
นั้นช้างเนี่ยมันไม่ค่อยอยู่ 1 ตัวในป่า
ไงมันไม่ค่อยอยู่ในตัวเดียวใน
ป่าช้างเนี่ยมันชอบอยู่รวมกันเป็น
ฝูงเหมือนเราเห็นสัตว์บางตัวใช่มั้ยอยู่
กันรวมกันหลายๆตัวเราเรียกเป็นฝูงแต่ช้าง
พิเศษอีกะ
อืเราไม่เรียกช้างหนึ
ฝูงแล้วเราเรียกว่าอะไรคะช้าง 1 โขง
ออช้าง 1 โขงโขลงนึงอาจจะมีสัก 2 ตัวเอ้ย
2 ตัว 5 ตัว 10 ตัวใช่มั้ยเพราะว่าอยู่
ในป่าเนี่ยเขาจะเป็นโขลงโขลงช้างที่จะออก
ไปหากินไปด้วยกันนะแต่เมื่อกี้ครูชิบอก
ว่าช้ช้างอยู่ในป่าเนี่ยเราเรียกว่าช้าง 1
ตัวช้าง 2 ตัวแต่ช้างอยู่โดนจับมาเลี้ยง
แล้วเนี่ยเป็นช้าง 1 เชือกช้าง 2 เชือก
ค่ะแต่มีอีกนะครูชิ
ค่ะถ้าเป็นช้างพิเศษอืที่จับมาแล้วก็ถวาย
ในหลวงให้ในหลวงเป็นช้างที่มีสีพิเศษ
ลักษณะพิเศษเนี่ยอืช้างของในหลวงเนี่ย
เค้าเรียกช้าง 1 ตัวช้าง 1 เชือกมั้ยล่ะ
คะไม่เรียกค่ะเรียกช้าง 1 ช้างเห็นมะช้าง
1 ช้างช้าง 2 ช้างอืมเห็นมั้ยพิเศษจริงๆ
เนาะพิเศษค่ะช้างเนี่ยจะเปลี่ยนลักษณะนาม
ไปตามไปตามเอ่อสถานที่นะเวลาอยู่ในป่า
เนี่ยก็เรียกเป็นตัวเวลามาอยู่กับคน
เลี้ยงก็เรียกเป็นเชือกเวลาให้กับพระ
มหากษัตริย์หรือในหลวงเนี่ยก็เรียกเป็น
ช้างเหมือนคนนะคน 1 คนเราไม่เรียกคน 1
ตัวนะอ่าแล้วคนก็ไม่ใช่ 1
เชือกนะใช่มเห็นมยพิเศษจริงๆมีตั้ง 3  3
อย่างที่เรียกเลยเนาะนะใช่
อือแล้วแล้วเวลาสัตว์ที่อยู่รวมกันเยอะๆ
ใช่มยสัตว์ต่างๆเช่นอะไรล่ะยีราฟอืนะคะ
ม้าลายม้าลายก็แบบม้าที่มีลายขาวดำขาวดำอ
นะเราก็เรียก 1 ฝูงก็คือมีเยอะๆแต่ช้าง
เนี่ยเราเรียกเมื่อสักครู่นี้เราบอกว่าเน
อันนี้เราก็จะคุยว่าโอตอนนี้ถ้าจะขึ้นไป
เขาใหญ่ขับเส้นทางที่จะไปเขาใหญ่ระวัง
ช้างด้วยตอนนี้โขงช้างเนี่ยออกจากป่ามาหา
กินเดินออกมาที่ถนนใช่ค่ะแล้วก็จริงๆแล้ว
อ่ะเเดินเป็นปกตินะครูชิเาจะมีเส้นทางที่
เขาจะเดินไปหาอาหารแล้วตอนเช้าเนี่ยก็จะ
เดินไปตอนเย็นก็จะเดินกลับอือเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยใครที่ขึ้นเขาใหญ่เนี่ยขับรถขึ้นไป
เนี่ยถ้าช่วงเช้านะเช้ามืดก็อาจจะเจอช้าง
ได้หรือตอนเย็นน่ะสัก 6 นน่ะบางทีครูปุ๊ก
เนี่ยนะเอ่อสามีขับรถขึ้นไปเนี่ยเราก็จะ
เจอช้างเหมือนกันค่ะอืนะเขาก็จะเดินที่
ถนนแต่ว่าห้ามไปบีบแตใส่เานะปนๆๆอ่าเพราะ
ว่าเชิญครับใช่เค้าเป็นใหญ่ค่ะในที่นั้น
นะเราเนี่ยเอาทถนนเนี่ยตัดผ่านที่ของเค้า
เราต้องให้เจ้าถิ่นนะให้เค้าเดินไป
ก่อนคือเค้าเป็นเจ้าของที่เป็นเจ้าของ
บ้านคือป่าเนี่ยยเป็นของเค้ามาก่อนแต่เรา
เนี่ยเอาถนนไปผ่านบ้านเค้าเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยก็ต้องเชิญเจ้าของบ้านไปก่อนให้เจ้า
ของบ้านไปก่อนแล้วเราค่อยขับรถผ่านบ้าน
เข้าไปอืมใช่ค่ะ
นะเราอย่าทำตัวเป็นเจ้าของใช่มั้ยที่จะ
แบบปิ้นๆอันนี้อาจจะอันตรายได้เพราะว่า
เอ่อโขลงช้างเนี่ยเขาคจะมีหัวหน้าใช่มั้ย
อ่าเค้าก็มีหัวหน้าที่เราเรียกว่าจ่าจ่า
โขงเนี่ยนะเป็นเป็นหัวหน้าช้างอันนี้จะ
เหมือนกับเป็นแบบผู้ดูแลผู้ยิ่ง
ใหญ่มาเฟียนิดหน่อยนะ
อแต่ว่า
เอ่อช้างเนี่ยที่เป็นตัวพูเนี่ยเค้าก็จะ
ดูแลโขงที่เป็นตัวเมียเป็นลูกเนี่ยได้
หลายตัวไงครูชิอืเห็นมั้ยแต่มันก็มีพิเศษ
อีกไงครูปุ๊กอย่างถ้าช้างตัวผู้เนี่ยนะ
ช้างตัวผู้หรือช้างผู้ชายเราก็ไม่เรียก
ช้างผู้ชายมเราก็เรียกตัวผู้นะถ้าเป็น
สัตว์ช้างตัวผู้เนี่ยเราจะมีชื่อเรียกนำ
หน้าเค้าค่ะอ้าเราเรียกว่าอะไรคะครูชิ
ช้างพรายอ่าช่างพายเช่นถ้าเค้าชื่อว่า
เอ่อ a ก็เป็นพาย a แสดงว่าเป็นผู้ชายอ่า
เป็นมิสเตอร์นนักเรียนบอกว่าเอ่อครูคะ
เค้าอยู่ในป่าเนี่ยเค้ามีชื่อหรอคะเรามัก
จะเรียกเค้าเพื่อเราจะจำเค้าได้ค่ะพอเห็น
เตัวสีแดงๆเราก็เรียกเค้าว่าพายแดงอืนะ
คือคือเขาจะมีเจ้าหน้าที่เนาะที่ดูแลนะ
กรมอุทยานที่เขาจะดูแลพวกสัตว์ป่าล่ะแล้ว
ก็เขาก็จะตั้งชื่อช้างแต่ละตัวเนี่ยว่า
ชื่ออะไรสำหรับการจำแล้วก็เป็นการคุยกัน
นะว่าอ้าอันนี้พ่อใหญ่มาแล้วครับพายพ่อ
ใหญ่พายใหญ่มาแล้วพายใหญ่
อ่าหรือเอ่ออะไรล่ะตัวตัวจุดพายจุดุด
อย่างเงี้ยเอาที่แบบว่าสามารถเห็นแล้วก็
จำได้ว่าเป็นเคเอ่อเจ้าหน้าที่มักจะตั้ง
ชื่อแบบนั้นแล้วก็จะเรียกคำนำหน้าช้างตัว
ผู้ว่าพายนะคะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยพายที่เรา
บอกนะมีมีงาแต่มีมั้ยคะว่าช้างตัวผู้ที่
ไม่มีงาอืมก็อาจจะมีสิคะครูชินะ
มีจริงๆค่ะอย่างอันเนี้ยคืองาเจะเล็กๆแบบ
เนี้ยค่ะไม่ใช่ว่าไม่มีเลยนะคะมีออกมาแต่
มัน
เล็กเราก็จะเรียกเราก็จะไม่เรียกเอ่อเค้า
ว่าเป็นพายค่ะเราจะมีคำนำหน้าเค้าใหม่เรา
เรียกเค้าว่าสีอ๋อช้างสีใช่ถ้านัก
เรียนได้ยินคำนี้เนี่ยว่าอันเนี้ยช้างสี
เนี่ยก็หมายถึงว่าเป็นเพศผู้นะเป็นตัว
ผู้นะแล้วก็เป็นช้างที่งาเนี่ยไม่ยาวงา
มันจะกุดๆสั้นๆอยู่ข้างในเนาะอืออกมาแบบ
เล็กๆอืน่ารักน่ารักนะออกมาไม่ยาวนะคแต่
เราก็รู้ว่าเค้าเป็นตัวผู้ใช่มั้ยเราก็จะ
เรียกเว่าสีถ้าเค้าชื่อว่าอะไรดีอ่ะ
ชื่อว่าว่าชื่อว่าดำเราก็เรียกสีดำนะ
ไม่ใช่พายดำนะเราก็เรียกเคคว่าสีดดำเพราะ
เคไม่มีงาอืคนมองไกลๆอาจจะเข้าใจว่าเค้า
เป็นตัวเมียไงเอ้าอเ้าถ้าอย่างงี้เนี่ย
ตัวผู้ที่มีงายาวๆเนาะก็เรเรียกว่าพายใช่
ถ้าตัวผู้งาสั้นๆเล็กๆนะเรียกว่าสีอืม
แล้วตัวเมียล่ะคะจะมีมั้ยตัวเมียเราเรียก
ว่าช้างพังค่ะช้างพังพังทุกอย่างเหรอคะ
ไม่ได้หมายถึงพังทำลายหรือว่างพังออกมานะ
คะเป็นชื่อที่เรานำหน้าเค้านะอย่างเช่น
ช้างตัวเนี้ยอาจจะแบบเอ่ออะไรล่ะเอ่อหวาน
นะอาจจะตั้งชื่อว่าอ้อยนะคะเราก็อาจจะบอก
ว่าพังอ้อย
ไม่ใช่ิวอ้อยใช่มั้ยิวอ้อยกูวคือเรามอง
ว่าเ้าเนี่ยเป็นเป็นช้างที่ชอบกินอ้อย
เยอะไงเราอาจจะให้เาเรียกเขาว่าช้างพัง
อ้อยแสดงว่าเป็นตัวเมียชื่อว่าอ้อยแบบนี้
ออแล้วถ้าชื่อว่าสีชมพูเพราะว่าผิวก็อาจ
จะแบบไม่ได้ดำมากไงเาก็อาจจะแบบพังชมพู
อืน่ารักเลยเนอะอไม่น่ากลัวเลย
พังชมพูพังน้ำอ้อยพังอะไรอีกอ่ะคือตั้ง
ชื่อแล้วก็มีคำนำหน้าว่าพังไงแสดงว่ารู้
เลยว่าเป็นตัวเมียนะไม่ต้องไปขอดูนะคะแบบ
ดูหน่อยซิตัวผู้หรือตัวเมียไม่ต้อง
ดูเจ้าหน้าที่เเช็คมาแล้วว่าะตัวเนี้ย
เป็นตัวเมียด้วยนะแล้วก็อเพราะว่าเค้าไม่
มีงาใช่มยูชิใช่เขาไม่มีงาค่ะแล้วที่
สำคัญบางคนบางตัวบางเชือกถ้าเอามาเลี้ยง
แล้วก็ต้องแบบบางเชือกบางเชือกก็มีลูกไง
แล้วก็ดูดนมแบบเนี้ยอันนี้ตัวเมียแน่
ๆ
เออนะน่ารักนะช้างเนี่ยเป็นสัตว์ที่น่า
รักมากๆนะทีนี้นักเรียนอาจจะสงสัยไงครู
กุ๊กอ้าแล้วมีมั้ยคะที่แบบว่าช้างพัง
เนี่ยมีงาเออเออตัวเมียแล้วมีงามีมั้ยครู
ชิมีค่ะแต่งาก็ไม่ยาวไงงาก็ออกมาแบบสั้นๆ
เหมือนเหมือนสีนะแต่เราไม่เรียกเค้าว่า
สีเพราะเค้าเป็นช้างพังไงอืแต่เราก็ไม่
เรียกส่วนที่ยื่นออกมาว่างาเพราะงาจะมี
แค่ตัวผู้แต่ถ้างามันออกมาจากตัวเมียเรา
เรียกงาว่าขนาย
โอ้โหทำไมมันเรียกสับสนช้างมีชื่อเรียก
ส่วนต่างๆแตกต่างกับสัตว์อื่นๆเพราะว่า
ช้างเป็นสัตว์พิเศษ
อืนะเพราะเราก็ยกย่องว่าช้างเนี่ยเป็น
สัตว์พิเศษจริงๆในประเทศไทยเนาะนะเป็น
ช้างที่แบบนะถ้าลักษณะที่ถูกต้องลักษณะดี
เนี่ยคือในสมัยก่อนเนี่ยนั้นในหลวงก็จะ
เอานั่งไปสำหรับไปสู้รบกับศัตรูเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยเก็เลยให้เกียรติให้ยกย่องนะ
ช้างก็เลย
โอ้โหเรียกซะอืนักเรียนบอกโอ๊เมา
ค่ะ
อ่ะแต่มีช้างที่เรารู้สึกว่าช้างก็มีส่วน
ที่เป็นแบบอันตรายเหมือนกันนะเ้าอันตราย
ยังไงูชิ
อย่างช้างบางตัวเนี่ยเราเรียกว่าช้างตก
มันตกมันเนี่ยทั้งตัวผู้ตัวเมียมยคะมีได้
ทั้งตัวผู้ตัวเมียค่ะที่เป็นช้างตกมันอ้า
แล้วเราจะรูยัง
ไงเราต้องรู้ก่อนว่าช้างเนี่ยมันตกมัน
เพราะอะไรอือ่าเพราะว่าช้างที่มีอาการตก
มันเนื่องจากช้างเนี่ยมีความสมบูรณ์ความ
สมบูรณ์อะไรความสมบูรณ์ทางเพศคือคือโต
เต็มวัยแล้วอ่ะคือฮอร์โมนนะใช่ฮอร์โมนมัน
มันมันมันมันดีแล้วมันพร้อมที่จะแต่งงาน
ใช่มยใช่ค่ะแล้วก็อายุของช้างที่อยู่ใน
ช่วงที่มักจะตกมันก็คือ 20 ถึง 40 ช่วง
นี้สามารถตกมันได้ตลอดค่ะขึ้นอยู่กับห
ฮอร์โมนเพศเนี่ยมีความตื่นตัวทางเพศเต็ม
ที่ตอนไหนนะคะหรืออาจจะมีส่วนต่างๆเกี่ยว
กับอากาศนะคอากาศร้อนมากผิดปกติเหมือนกับ
ช่วงปีเนะอากาศร้อนมากผิดปกติช้างที่มี
ฮอร์โมนทางเพศจะมีออาการที่แบบหงุดหงิด
อืมก็อาจจะเป็นเหตุของการตกมันได้
อืนะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยถ้าเรารู้ว่าช้างตก
มันเนี่ยไม่ควรจะเข้าไปอยู่ใกล้ๆเลยเพราะ
ว่าเค้ามีอารมณ์หรือว่าฮอร์โมนมันเปลี่ยน
เนามันอาจจะทำให้เขาหงุดหงิดแล้วก็เคยแบบ
เป็นช้างใจดีก็อาจจะใจร้ายก็ได้ใช่มยนะ
ใช่ค่ะครูปุ๊กทีนี้ถ้าถ้าเกิดเราจะสังเกต
นะว่าช้างที่ตกมันเนี่ยเป็นยังไงเขาบอก
ว่าต้องดูตรงนี้ค่ะคือช้างตกมันก็เกิดได้
ทั้งช้างที่เลี้ยงแล้วก็ช้างที่อยู่ในป่า
นะที่ไหนที่ไหนก็ตกมันได้แม้นแต่อยู่ใน
สวนสัตว์
ออแล้วเพราะฉะนั้นต้องดูยังไงคะต้อง
สังเกตตรงไหนคะเนี่ยเา้าบอกข้างๆตาเห็น
มั้ยคะมันมีรูแล้วก็มีน้ำมันไหลออกมา
เนี่ยค่ะ
อ่าพอเวลาน้ำมันมันมันไหลออกมาเนี่ยช้าง
จะได้กลิ่นน้ำมันตัวเนี้ยมันจะอารมณ์มัน
จะแบบพุ่งพุ่งพลาดหงุดหงิดนะคะเนี่ยมันจะ
มีน้ำมันออกมาตรงนี้จริงๆพุยตายขนตา
งอนไปดูที่ขนตาอีกนะอ่าอก็คือต้องสังเกต
ที่บริเวณขมับหรือว่าข้างๆหูเนาะใช่
ระหว่างตากับหูอยู่ตรงกลางระหว่างตากับหู
นะจะมีน้มันไหลออกมานะเนื่องจากฮอร์โมน
เนาะมันมันน่าจะเหมือนฟีโรโมนมยแบบเหมือน
มันทำให้มีกลิ่น
อ่าเรียกพอได้กลิ่นแล้วเนี่ยมันมันก็ทำ
ให้เกิดอาการหงุดหงิดใช่่มยอืมันอาจจะ
เหมือนเรียกตัวเมียหรือว่าเรียกตัวผู้
หรืออะไรอย่างงี้หรือเปล่า
อืนะธรรมชาติของสัตว์เนาะนะก็จะมีนะแต่
ว่าของช้างเนี่ยนักเรียนต้องสังเกตถ้ามี
น้ำมันปุ๊บเนี่ยอย่าเข้าใกล้แม้นแต่ว่า
บางทีเราไปเที่ยวสวนสัตว์เนี่ยนะเราก็ไม่
รู้เขาจะอารมณ์หงุดหงิดตอนไหนแล้วยิ่งแบบ
อากาศร้อนนะตกมันด้วยแล้วบางทีบางคนอาจจะ
แบบมีกล้วยเอาให้แล้วก็พอเาจะรับไม่ให้
ให้ไม่ให้ให้ไม่ให้เนี่ยเายิ่งหงุดหงิด
จะโกรธมากนะอออาจจะทำอันตรายได้ใช่นะอถ้า
แบบครูเคยเห็นแบบเด็กๆไงกลัวเวลายื่นให้
พอช้างเอางวงมาจะรับเาก็หดอ่ะอ่ะยื่นไป
ใหม่เเอางวงมาจะรับเอาหดอีกเนี่ยอันเนี้ย
ช้างจะโกรธนะแล้วก็ระวังเจะทำร้ายได้นะ
อื้อหือ
เพราะฉะนั้นถ้าเราดูแลลูกนะแล้วเอาให้ลูก
สอนให้ลูกให้อาหารก็ต้องแบบกล้าแล้วก็ให้
เลยไม่แบบเข้าๆออกๆแบบนี้อันตรายหรือถ้า
เกิดเราเห็นว่าช้างกำลังตกมันอย่าไปยุ่ง
อย่าไปเข้าใกล้หรือห่างยิ่งดีค่ะนะเราไม่
รู้เาจะหงุดหงิดอารมณ์เสียตอนไหนนะเราก็
จะเห็นช้างที่อาละวาดอาละวาดก็คือเอาเอา
งวงเนี่ยฟาดฟาดๆดฟาดทุกอย่างที่แบบฉันไม่
พอใจนะคะระบายอารมณ์เขาบอกบางทีควานช้าง
ควานช้างก็คือคนที่เลี้ยงช้างอ่ะนะคนที่
ดูแลช้างคนที่เลี้ยงช้างก็จะเอาเค้าเนี่ย
ลงน้ำแต่บางทีเนี่ยควานช้างบางคนก็อารมณ์
ร้อนนะแล้วก็ใช้ความรุนแรงไปยั่วอารมณ์เ
อีกบางทีก็ช้างก็เอ่อทำร้ายความช้างเช่น
เดียวกันแต่เราก็มีเรื่องที่แบบคนที่อยู่
ในเขตที่ใกล้ๆป่าที่ช้างอยู่อ่ะบางที
เนี่ยไม่รู้ว่าเราเนี่ยไปอยู่ใกล้บ้าน
เค้าหรือเค้าเนี่ยอยากจะเข้ามาหาเรานะคะ
ก็จะมีข่าวบ่อยๆนะว่าช้างเนี่ยบุก
บ้านอันนี้นอันนี้เช้างพายแน่ๆ
ค่ะนะจำได้เนาะนักเรียนช้างภายก็คือช้าง
ตัว
ผู้นะเพราะว่างามันยาวแล้วค่ะนะมันไม่ใช่
สีด้วยเพราะว่าถ้าสีงามันจะสั้นนิด
เดียวอ่ามันไม่โค้งแบบนี้ด้วยอือันนี้น่า
รักนะเนี่ยถึงจะทางบ้านก็ยังน่ารักคือ
ช้างตัวเนี้ยดื้อค่ะอาจจะเป็นเพราะว่า
เป็นช้างวัยรุ่นนะคะมีเจ้าหน้าที่ที่
พยายามจะไล่เนี่ยแต่ช้างก็จะดื้อไม่สนใจ
จะบุกเข้ามาในบ้านไม่รู้ว่าจมูกดีหรือ
เปล่าคิดว่าแล้วก็พังถูกที่นะคพังเข้ามา
ในห้องครัวห้องที่ทำอาหารนะคะแล้วก็มา
เปิดฝาหม้อดูมีอะไรกินนะคะแล้วบางทีก็เอา
ไปทั้งหม้อเลยค่ะหม้ออาหาร
นะขโมยเหรอใช่ค่ะคนี้ก็แบบว่ากูกุ๊กจะ
เห็นนะคะมีซีเมนต์เห็นมั้ยคะค่ะมีมี
ซีเมนต์เนี่ยมาซ่อมบ้านช้างก็พังอีก
ค่ะซีเมนตก็เลยสีไม่เหมือนกันใช่ค่ะก่อน
หน้านี้พังแล้วก็เข้ามาเอาอาหารเค้าก็
โอเคไม่เป็นไรก็มีซีเมนต์ใหม่มาปิดอันนี้
ก็มาพังอีกค่ะน่าจะติดใจนะเพราะว่ารู้
แล้วว่าอาหารบ้านนี้อร่อยค่ะอร่อยกว่า
เอ่อกล้วยที่อยู่ในป่าในป่าเนาะก็เลยเข้า
มาใหม่นะมันมีกลิ่นอาหารด้วยไงช้างเนี่ย
ุกดู
ดิซ่อมกี่ครั้งกี่ครั้งช้างก็บอกว่าฉัน
รู้ว่าตรงนี้แหละมีอาหารอืไม่รู้รู้ได้
ยังไงอจมูกดีไงอันเนี้ยก็มีรูค่ะที่มอง
เห็นตรงนี้แต่งตัวแบบเนี้ยก็คือเจ้าหน้า
ที่ของกรมอุอุทยานเนาะใช่ตอนหลังเนี่ย
เจ้าหน้าที่ก็เลยต้องจับช้างพายตัวเนี้ย
นะไปปล่อยในป่าที่ลึกไปดูที่มีแหล่งอาหาร
ตราบดันที่เขาอยู่ใกล้ๆเมืองอาหารมันอาจ
จะน้อยไม่มีแหล่งอาหารไม่มีแหล่งน้ำก็เลย
เข้ามาบุกบ้านบ้านคนอคือเวลาเจ้าหน้าที่
ไล่อ่ะช้างตัวอื่นก็เข้าป่าลึกไปไปหา
อาหารข้างในนะแต่ช้างตัวเนี้ยไม่ยอมไปค่ะ
น่าจะติดใจอาหารบ้านนี้เอ้าแล้วก็หากิน
ได้ง่ายไงูชิถ้าเข้าป่าเนี่ยไม่รู้เดิน
เท่าไหร่ถึงจะเจออาหารแล้วก็อาจจะไปเจอ
ช้างที่มันตัวใหญ่กว่าใช่มั้ยแล้วก็อาจจะ
ต้องสู้กันเพื่อแย่งอาหารก็ได้ไม่รู้เนาะ
แต่ว่าอยู่ตรงเนี้ยอ่าที่นี่แหละยังไงก็
มีอาหารแล้วก็อร่อยด้วยรสชาติไม่เหมือน
ของที่อยู่ใน
ป่าตอนแรกเนี่ยเจ้าของบ้านก็บอกไม่เป็นไร
หรอกช้างเข้าบ้านมากินก็ให้กินไปตอนหลัง
มันเริ่มเยอะขึ้นเรื่อยๆแล้วช้างกินเยอะ
แวงคนกินหมดตอนหลังคนก็ชักไม่ไหวแล้วก็
สร้างกำแพงไม่ไหวก็เลยฟ้องเจ้าหน้าที่
เจ้าหน้าที่ก็เลยต้องจับช้างแล้วก็ไปหา
ค่ะป่าที่มีอาหารเยอะๆมีแหล่งน้ำให้อยู่
แล้วก็มีช้างมีสังคมของช้างช้างก็จะได้ไป
อยู่รวมกันเป็นโขลงค่ะอืออ่าก็อัน
นี้
นะถ้านักเรียนขับรถขึ้นเขาใหญ่นะถ้าลงไป
ทางจังหวัดปราจีนบุรีนะเค้าจะมีช่วงฤดูเ
ที่เค้าเก็บอ้อยเนอะตัดอ้อยเี่จะมีรถที่
บรรทุกอ้อยเยอะๆอ่ะเข้าจะมีช้างอยู่หลาย
เชือกเหมือนกันละเขาจะมาเก็บสวย
ค่ะเคจะมารอเลยแล้วมีช้างใช่แชงมายืนไปมี
จะมีเค้าเรียกอะไรอ่ะตัวขาใหญ่ใช่มั้ยนะไ
ตัวคะที่ที่มาดักคิดว่าน่าจะประมาณซัก 3
ตัวแต่ว่าเมาทีละตัวนะ 1 ตัว 2 ตัวอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะอ้าไม่ได้มาทีเดียวเยอะๆแต่ว่าคน
ที่ขับรถที่ขนอ้อยน่ะเค้าจะเข้าใจพอพอเจอ
ปุ๊บเข้าจะจอดแล้วช้าก็จะเอางวงเนี่ยไป
เกี่ยวอ้อยมาสักกำนึงปึ๊บแล้วก็เอาลงปุ๊บ
นะเค้าก็จะปล่อยให้ไปได้อ๋อเก็บภาษีเก็บ
ค่าผ่าเก็บค่าผ่านทางจะผ่านทางเโอ้โหช้า
เดี๋ยวนี้ก็ฉลาดนะเอ้านี่บ้านของฉันเธอมี
เธอขับรถผ่านบ้านฉันจ่ายมาอ้อย 1 กำมนะคะ
ไปแล้วเดี๋ยวก็คันที่ 2 ก็มาก็แอดยุดใช่
จับไ
มาเป็นที่รู้กันใช่ค่ะคนที่ขับรถส่งอ้อย
แถวนั้นเขาจะรู้ว่าบางทียังไม่ได้ถึงขนาด
ออกมาที่ถนนนะเขาก็จะจอดให้เขจะอยู่ข้าง
ทางแล้วเก็อ่ะจอดปุ๊บก็เกี่ยวออกมา 1 กำ
เขาก็ขับผ่านไปอันนี้เข้าใจกัน
อันนี้อยู่ด้วยกันได้ไม่ทะเลาะกันแต่บาง
ที่ก็แบบทะเลาะกันเหมือนกันนะเพราะเวลา
แบบโอหคนปลูกสับปะรดอ่ะอยากจะเอาสับปะรด
ขายแล้วสับปะรดกำลังสุกพรุ่งนี้จะได้เงิน
จะได้เงินแสนอยู่ๆช้างมาค่ะ 1 โขงเนี่ย
รืดสับปะรดหายไปหมดเลยเงินแสนหายโกรธ
ทะเลาะกันกับช้างใช่ค่ะก็มีค่ะก็ก็วันนี้
เอาเออหมีเรื่องมาเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังนะ
เกี่ยวกับช้างเนี่ยสนุกมากนะแต่ว่าต้องรอ
คลิปต่อๆไปแล้วค่ะเพราะว่าวันนี้เนี่ยหมด
เวลาแล้วโอเคได้ค่ะก็หมดเวลาแล้วก็ต้องลา
นักเรียนกันไปนะคะมีโอกาสนักเราจะมาคุย
เรื่องเกี่ยวเรื่องใหญ่ๆอีก
่ะนะวันนี้ก็ขอบคุณครูชิค่ะแล้วก็ขอบคุณ
นักเรียนค่ะสวัสดีค่ะพบกันสดีค่ะ